mic Dalzell is one of millions of people
around the country living in a 4G black
spot like many of us he's reliant on his
mobile phone for almost everything but
at home he has no signal to make calls
text or use data and there are fears a
digital divide around the country is
making people like him feel cut off very
Australian because you know I've got a
one-year-old girl and I'm also run an
amateur football team so obviously my
phone on what's up especially is going
up all the time
with the football organising and there
if there's anything wrong baby
you have to come home or just keeping in
touch with family it's can be quite
quite annoying and if the Wi-Fi goes
down then it's they can be very very
painful days yeah while coverage has
improved from a year ago 82% of rural
areas still don't receive 4G coverage
from all the major network providers
it's hardest to access in Scotland where
4G signal is only available in 31% of
areas that's compared to the national
average of 63 percent 40 is very
important to rural business in rural
communities to ensure that they do get
do indeed get fast reliable broadband
services to support their community
projects and indeed the small businesses
and those who work from home Greater
Manchester is supposed to be at the
heart of the northern powerhouse but
even in areas around the city centre
people still complain of no coverage so
just homes in remote's countryside here
in Stockport coverage can be poor and
mobile phone services unreliable service
providers have coverage obligations in
their licensing agreements with comm the
deadlines for them to meet those
obligations is fast approaching at the
end of the year but it's not clear if
they'll meet them Ofcom
is working with the government to relax
planning laws so more mobile phone masts
can be built in the countryside while
that won't be popular with everyone for
people like Mike it would mean less time
in during the Stockport weather
searching for signal sally Lockwood Skye
knee
stop port